let me see the numbers in the arsenal
for eric fetty last start was july 16th
against the padres took the 24-8 loss in
that one gave up six runs on three hits
over just one in the third inning
eric fetty facing miguel rojas the
marlin shortstop and he blasts one to
right field
soto angling back and on one pitch
eric fetty has one out to get his night
started is a good start to his night
tonight
toward left center andrew stevenson
chasing he's closing and he puts it away
ground ball left side turner on the move
with one bounce the stretch
and the inning is over a five pitch
inning for aaron fetty
marlon's handed over to nick knight it
was a game that was supposed to be
started
by sandy alcatra he has been placed on
the bereavement list
so it's neither tonight making his
fifth start of the year and 10th game in
his big league career
he's pounding the strike zone he's going
after hitters
and a ground ball rojas goes to panic
and onto first there's a double play
there's a called strike three inside
corner
nice job by neither to work around the
walk it's a little double play in there
too
scoreless after one now betty starts the
wind
payoff pitch to duvall swung on ground
ball toward the left side cut off by
turner to his left
little jump throw on the move in time to
bell duval is out
and fenney rocks into the motion the
one-two pitch swinging the ground ball
toward the middle
again turner to his left gets to it
behind the bag at second
he whips a throw sidearm to bell in time
for the out
a little two-out noise here back-to-back
singles panic in leon and a chance for
john bertie
toward the second baseman escobar on a
hop and he'll throw him out to retire
the side so fetty works around a couple
of two out hits
no score after an inning and a half
harrison dutily off the bottom of the
second
there's harrison first ball hitting
lifts wood in the air to center field
playable for martay
just a couple of steps left to straight
away centers got it one pitch went out
for neither who's got four outs on 15
pitches already
a rough patch and now they've won three
in a row as para sends one out to left
for birdie
and that's out number two and he gets
the fastball and serves it in the center
and that'll move stevenson over to third
and he gets a piece of it and grounds to
the right side
panic makes the play and the nationals
will strand a pair
we'll tap her back to the mound fetty
with the long underhand
toss
toward the line soto giving chase
closing and
makes the running grab in fair ground
before crossing the line
here's the swing of the chopping ground
ball wide at first bell has it
he'll flip to fetty covering it first in
time to get diaz the side retired
one's lifted out to right field backing
up his panic called off by duvall who
puts it away for the first out
ground ball and diaz over there with the
shift and they turn the double play
it goes five six three but a double play
nonetheless
that's two for niner tonight
aguilar takes outside a four pitch walk
in the marlins have him loaded
faces loaded nobody out panic first ball
hitting a bouncing ball to second looks
like it's going to be two escobar to
turner
on the bell double play but in from
third base martay
little tapper and it stays fair and bell
will make
the play to retire the side
he bounces one to the shortstop miguel
rojas has it moving to his left on the
first and a quick out to begin this
fourth for nighter
so now gerardo para comes to the plate
it'll be another two again gerardo parra
and that one is popped up into very
short left field under a john birdie
he's got it
two outs now in the fourth thing with
harrison the first base it looked to
andrew
stevenson who worked to walk in the
second harrison running
well hit to right field this one's going
to be over duvall and one hop
off the wall staying in play allowing
harrison to come in with the game-tying
run
nationals won marlins one
[Applause]
out to center field marte makes the
catch
sliding play able to pick it off the
turf and that ends the inning
and eric fetty has his first strikeout
but he's trying to finish him off
and he does looking to strike out the
side
and he does third chance for turner
against nick knighter
double play ball to short in the first
to fly to right in the third
ground ball is he going to get another
one
he sure is he gets a third double play
ball
and twice it's been turner
down he goes that is four strikeouts in
a row for eric fetty
in the air to deep left field our way
back to the track
backpedaling now as he makes the catch
[Applause]
now the set of the pitch swinging the
ground ball up the third base line fair
pass the diving third baseman isan diaz
up with it quickly
is the left fielder birdie getting over
toward the line with josh bell the
batter
he will turn around and bat for the
right side of the play
ground up the middle diving stop rojas
to second out onto first
what a double play josh bell out on the
six
6-4-3
twin killing rojas to panic to augie
larmigie comes up big
and he gets escobar to chase a fastball
upstairs out number one in the eighth
poke to right over the leaping aguilar
and turner is on board for soto
angular tried to climb the ladder
couldn't get up to it and one of the
fastest guys in baseball is on first and
juan soto gonna see something hit now
soto in the air drifting back is rojas
he'll put it away
on 1-2 bell got under one lifts it in
the air to left center
marte over calls off birdie makes the
catch to end the inning
it's up to andrew stevenson now to avoid
extra innings borrows 1-2 pitch
is in there for a called strike three
and the marlins have the tie-breaking
man 90 feet away with one out and i'll
see if john birdie can come through
rinsing the third one out 10th inning in
a 1-1 game and on 3-2 that's inside he
laid off ball four
so now marlon's at the corners and jorge
alfaro is going to get a shot here as a
pinch hitter
and alfaro down the left field line
that'll get down and get to the wall
brinson scores
birdie's on his way to third he is held
there and it's an rbi
pinch hit double for jorge alfaro to
give the marlins the lead in the 10th
miguel rojas coming up with runners on
second and third and one out
pereira sets up inside and rojas hits a
fly ball out to center field stevenson
back
he makes the catch it'll be deep enough
to score birdie
a sacrifice fly for maggie rowe and a
3-1 lead for the marlin
and pereira fly ball out towards center
it's going to be martay to make the play
stevenson stays where he is
on a hop to birdie at second backs him
up to the outfield grass and that's out
number two
two outs stevenson the place runners
still at second base
escobar one and two
line drive caught by aguilar at first
jesus aguilar takes away a hit and
ends the game it's a marlins win